so the biden administration started
doing all kinds of things almost
immediately after joe biden was
inaugurated in january but the very
first thing they did the first big
policy change they made and the one
they've stuck to
most deciduously has been to open our
southern border
not simply to latin america but to the
world
now why did they do that why is that the
one thing
they did immediately and have kept doing
well of course because they want to
change who lives in this country and
they're doing
that to undermine democracy itself when
you
change who votes you change the outcome
of elections and they believe by opening
the border
they can ensure permanent control of our
political system but the democratic
party
for generations that's not a conspiracy
theory
they say it out loud all the time and
attack
you if you knowed it dick durbin who's a
senator purportedly from illinois just
said it out loud on the floor of the
senate a few days ago
last week the new york times published
an op-ed and we're giving the title here
directly quote
there is no good reason you should have
to be a citizen to vote
in other words the millions coming in
should be able to choose your government
the author of that piece argues that
actually
non-citizens contribute just as much to
this country as people who are
born here and they should be allowed to
pick your government
that doesn't scare you nothing will
victor davis hansen is a senior fellow
at the hoover institution he joins us
tonight professor thanks so much for
coming on so they scream at you
if you repeat their own words back to
them but i think it's pretty clear
they're not even hiding it
that the whole point of their
immigration policy is to ensure
political control
replace the population get a different
outcome am i misreading this
no you're not and i think it was really
important you stress the urgencies just
as we're seeing the efforts to destroy
the electoral college or pack the court
or have a national voter law they feel
that the constituency
of the present demography is not on
their side so they can't wait
to legally have residents come with
green cards and go through a lengthy
process of citizenship
because they don't think they're going
to be in power or they won't have this
moment
so they want to have residents
immediately become equal to citizens and
they forget that citizens
they know that citizenship is the
foundation of western civilization
tucker we had
a long period of settled civilization
but was only 2700 years ago when
in the classical world people said wait
a minute we are permanent fixed peoples
we have identifiable borders
we can make our own laws and elect our
own officials and take governance in our
own hands
we can't do that if we're migratory
tribes or we don't have a subtle space
or we don't have shared and collective
customs and traditions
that develop from settlement so when we
look at people crossing the border two
million of them
are scheduled in the next 12 months we
don't know who these people are
tucker we don't know if they speak their
language if we don't know if they share
our values
that we don't even know if they've ever
voted before and the idea that the
moment they come
across and that's the first decision
they made was to break
u.s law the second will be to reside
here illegally
they would be co-equal to a citizen
defies the whole concept of
of civilization and remember
citizenship's already eroded it started
out it's mentioned
several times in the constitution as an
assumption you don't even have to define
it
but it used to be the idea that a
citizen could only
elect hold elected office could only
vote could only go
in and out of the country at his own
permission and will
and could serve in the military and was
subject to the laws of the united states
and now we see those are mostly eroded
and we're down to just the only thing
that separates a citizen from somebody
crossing the border on
day one was that they they could not
hold office and they could not vote yet
already people in some jurisdictions
school board elections in california are
voting and there's talk about even
people holding office
when that happens then we're no
different than rome with people just
in the late 5th century a.d coming
across the roman borders
huns vandals goss with no difference in
their status
and roman citizens and you know what
happened after that
yeah and this is being done
intentionally stealing our country from
american citizens that's exactly what
this is
and we're allowing it i appreciate your
coming on tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else